entre llamas así se encuentra el centro
sur de chile donde hay más de 170
incendios forestales en activo que ya
han arrasado más de 14.000 hectáreas han
dañado más de un centenar de viviendas y
han dejado varios muertos entre ellos
miembros del equipo de bomberos y
civiles son personas que se desplazaban
por caminos en un caso un camino
principal en otro caso un camino
interior se desplazaban en vehículos en
un caso se calcinaron porque fueron
alcanzados por el fuego en el otro
sufrieron un accidente probablemente
tratando de escapar del fuego los
incendios se concentran en las regiones
de ñuble y bío-bío y también en maule y
la araucanía de momento no hay previsión
de que los incendios vayan a extinguirse
a pesar de que los bomberos han
conseguido controlar algunos una
situación a que obligó al presidente
Gabriel boric a cancelar sus vacaciones
y trasladarse a la zona ya en Concepción
seguimos trabajando para combatir los
incendios forestales y apoyar a las
familias con la mayor fuerza posible las
alertas rojas y las órdenes de
evacuación han obligado a muchos a
buscar refugio en albergues ya que las
llamas han dejado a muchos sin casa y
han forzado la evacuación de municipios
enteros terrible porque esfuerzo de año
de mi hermano de 2017 que no veíamos
algo así
al vecinos los vecinos están sacando
pocas cosas y uno y llega la ayuda pero
uno ve que parece que no fuera
suficiente lo único que quiere que
llegue agua que el helicóptero que
llegue luego de conaf que llegue todo el
mundo y chile está en medio de una ola
de calor principal causa de los
incendios este viernes las temperaturas
en la zona han rozado los 40 grados
celsius y se esperan fuertes vientos que
podrían empeorar las conflagraciones